exploratory data analysis or eda is a
method used by data scientists to
analyze data sets and summarize their
main characteristics it helps determine
how best to manipulate data sources to
get the answers you need making it
easier to discover patterns spot
anomalies test the hypotheses or to
check assumptions
you know in fact it's it's quite a lot
like hunting for buried treasure
let me explain
meet nate the treasure hunter and sophie
the data scientist when it comes to
treasure and insights they both go about
things in much the same way you see nate
our treasure hunter starts out by
identifying a potential treasure trove
location
in the same way sophie the data
scientist starts by identifying a data
set that looks promising
nate he then scopes out the area looking
for clues that there is indeed treasure
to be found and in the same way
sophie looks at the data set looking for
patterns or anomalies that could be
exploited
our treasure hunter then starts digging
looking for the treasure the data
scientist starts manipulating the data
looking for hidden patterns
and finally on a good day nate it finds
the treasure and brings it back to be
enjoyed and sophie well sophie finds the
insights from the data set and brings
them back to the business to be used so
when it comes to finding what they're
looking for treasure and insights you
could say that nate and sophie well they
have a lot in common
so the main purpose of exploratory data
analysis or e
d
a
is to analyze and summarize data sets
now there are four primary types of eda
which we can classify
into two subgroups so there's uni
variate
as the first subgroup and then there's
multiple
as the second subgroup
univariate data is data that can be
described just using
one variable while multivariate can be
described using multiple variables
now within univariate there are actually
two other classifications there's
non-graphical
and graphical
the main purpose of univariate analysis
is to describe the data and find
patterns that exist within it and since
it's a single variable it doesn't deal
with causes or relationships
now common types of univariate graphics
include stem and leaf plots which show
all the data values and the shape of the
distribution and there's also histograms
that's a bar plot in which each bar
represents the frequency or proportion
of cases for a range of values
multivariate non-graphical
well that is typically used for
techniques that generally show the
relationship between two or more
variables of the data through cross
tabulation or statistics and then
multivariate
graphics
well some examples of that include
grouped bar charts which each group
represents one level of one of the
variables and each bar within a group
represents the levels of the other
variable there's also bubble charts heat
maps and run charts as well
now some of the most common data science
tools
that we have
available
to use to create eda well those include
python
and
r
python and eda can be used together to
identify missing values in the data set
which is important so you can decide how
to handle missing values for machine
learning and the r language is widely
used among statisticians in data science
in developing statistical observations
and data analysis
using eda data scientists can identify
obvious errors better understand
patterns within the data detect outliers
and find interesting relations among the
variables using exploratory analysis
ensures the results they produce are
valid and applicable to any desired
business outcome and goal and once eda
is complete and the insights are drawn
its features can then be used for more
sophisticated data analysis or modeling
like well like helping nate
find that buried treasure
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe
thanks for watching